the omicron variant of covet 19 spooks
the globe anthony fauci announces he is
the voice of science again and joe biden
struggles to respond i'm benchmare this
is the bench bureau show
today's show is sponsored by
expressivevpn i protect my data with vpn
so should you visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first using the internet
without expressvpn is like leaving your
laptop exposed at a coffee shop table
while you run to the bathroom
most of the time probably okay but then
there's that one time where you go to
the bathroom you come out and there's
some weird guys just reading your emails
why would you just do that why wouldn't
you close your computer well do the same
thing when you use expressvpn because
here's the thing every time you use
public wi-fi somebody could be snooping
on your data looking over your shoulder
expressvpn puts a stop to this it
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet so
your online activity cannot be seen by
anyone i use expressvpn on all my
devices it works on everything phones
laptops even routers so everyone who
shares your wifi can still be protected
even if they don't have expressvpn is
expressvpn on my phone cause i'm on it
all the time use it on my computer as
well the best part is using expressvpn
it's as easy as closing that laptop when
you head off to the coffee shop bathroom
expressvpn is the world's number one
rated vpn by mashable the verge
countless others so if you're like me
believe your online activity is your
business secure yourself visit
expressvpn.com
ben today again that's
expressvpn.com you can get an extra
three months for free when you use
expressvpn.com
ben okay quick reminder before we
actually get to the news today like
today it's the last day to get 50 off
your daily wear membership by using code
dw50 i'm just going to ask you need to
do it please just do it seriously if
you've been considering it for years now
number one is the best deal you're gonna
get all year we do it like once a year
we may not do it next year fifty percent
off your daily weight membership but
you're also helping us fight because
that's what we do here right we are the
people who are going out and hiring gina
carano when she gets fired from disney
plus for no reason at all to make a
movie with us and saving her from the
cancellation pile we are the folks who
are doing the investigative reporting
that leads to the exposure of the
terrible public school system in loudoun
county and that can shift to political
race we are the folks who are fighting
the biden vaxx mandate by actually
taking the biden administration to court
in the sixth circuit court of appeals we
need your help to do all those things so
not only do you get all of our awesome
content and get deals on our merch store
which is now available and you get all
of the brand new stuff we're gonna be
doing next year and we have like a ton
of content i cannot wait to tell you
about tons more things we're going to
get involved with we need your help so
today is the last day to get 50 off your
daily wear membership use code dw50 and
get involved today alrighty so
omicron so we have a new variant of of
coven 19. you may be sensing already and
i'm taking this rather lightly and i am
and the reason that i'm taking this
rather lightly at this point is because
i have no evidence that we should be
taking this super seriously when i say
that what i mean is since delta i have
been of the opinion that you are going
to get immunity one of two ways either
naturally or via the vaccine that's the
whole story and it's your choice
i'm not under the weird assumption that
some people seem to be under that you're
never going to get covered i think that
you will i think that even if you get
vaccinated at some point you are likely
to get covered and because you're
vaccinated it's likely to be very mild
and we have great therapeutics that are
coming online we should have the new
pfizer therapeutic that is going to be
widely available in the next couple of
weeks
and so the only thing that would freak
me out at this point is if there was a
variant that emerged that was more
deadly
that's the only thing i'm not that
freaked out by a new variant that is
more transmissible again the reason
being there's no evidence whatsoever
that the t cell and b cell immunity that
has been created by the vaccine and by
previous natural immunity
is completely ineffective against the
new variant if it were it would be more
deadly okay if i'm just worried about
people getting infected by a new variant
i'm not that worried because that's been
true since delta so there's been a lot
of data out there about the fact that
for example the biden administration
under joe biden more people have died in
the united states of covid then they
then died under trump
and using joe biden's stupid math which
is the president is always responsible
for anything bad that happens that means
that joe biden really is solely
responsible but here's the thing i don't
think trump was responsible for the
deaths last year because no one did
great against covet unless you were a
tiny island nation that literally sealed
your borders like new zealand or like
taiwan or something okay or unless you
uh unless you basically
there is no ore there's no ore like that
was it if you're a tiny island if you
need a gray if you were not a tiny
island nation you eventually got hit end
of story okay and it moved through your
population and if you vaccinated fewer
people died and if you didn't vaccinate
more people died that's the whole thing
okay so
this year
a lot of people died not because
again
not because of joe biden okay i'm just
gonna put it out there a lot of people
this year did not die because of joe
biden a lot of people died this year
because delta was very transmissible and
a lot of people were not vaccinated
hey i can say that joe biden's language
with regard to science was super
counterproductive with regard to the
vaccines because it was i can say that
he sent mixed messages throughout the
pandemic which he did but in the end
every person has to make their own
decision as to whether they get
vaccinated or not and delta changed the
game as far as the number of people who
actually got the disease
so i've said since the vaccines were
available effectively speaking from a
public policy perspective the pandemic
is now over the reason that i've been
saying that is not because the pandemic
is over okay the pandemic is not over
people are still dying of covid the
question is from a public policy
perspective what can government do and
what can government not do now that
you've had the choice to get vaccinated
and the vaccines again they remain
durable not against infection they're
not but they remain very durable against
hospitalization and death by all
available data so far and i only care
about hospitalizations and death because
my kids all have colds this week i do
not care about how many people in the
united states get a cold this year i
don't care no one knows no one cares why
because my kids are going to be fine
covet is the only disease i've ever
heard of in my entire life where we care
deeply about how many people get it and
don't get hospitalized and die i don't
know why
the only thing i can think is that there
are a lot of people who have gotten in
the headspace of we have to panic and if
the stats on hospitalizations and deaths
are not sufficient to cause panic well
then we'll just go to the number of
people who are infected even the biden
administration has said we shouldn't be
paying attention to the infection
numbers we should only be paying
attention to the hospitalization and
death numbers
okay so i'm not particularly freaked out
by omicron at this point because there
is no evidence none zero zip zilch that
it is deadlier and more likely to affect
hospitalization than delta or then the
original
delta was much more transmissible not
more deadly
delta was more transmissible not more
likely to get you hospitalized if you
got it it's just more likely to give it
to you
as far as omicron so far as i'm aware
there's no data whatsoever that it is
more data that is more deadly or that
you're more likely to go to the hospital
if you get it then if you get delta or
if you get the original variant
and yet everybody is going nuts about
this which leads me to suggest that i
think the entire world has gone crazy
and people are
now
mentally and emotionally fragile
and something in the in the human psyche
has cracked over the amount of media
attention and governmental attention
that has been placed on a disease that
at this point
thanks to therapeutics is
rather treatable and
thanks to vaccines is not nearly as
deadly as we thought it was going to be
the beginning remember at the beginning
they were saying that this thing was
going to kill three four percent of the
people who got it unless you're over the
age of 75 and have a pre-existing
condition it ain't
okay we'll get to more on omicron and
what we know and what we don't in just
one second
first let's talk about something amazing
you can do for your family okay so i did
this for my family i went to my parents
garage they had a bunch of old films a
bunch of film reels and vhs tapes and
like stuff that they couldn't access
because who has the technology anymore i
took all that stuff i loaded it up in a
legacy box i sent it to legacy box and
legacy box sent back a digitized version
of all of this material
legacy box is the best way to preserve
your past send your legacy box filled
with old home movies and pictures
they'll do the rest they digitize your
moments onto a thumb drive the cloud or
dvd it's like magic my parents gave out
dvds to all the members of our family
with all those childhood memories
they've got preserved memories from from
their childhoods it's an amazing amazing
thing right it makes accessible stuff
that you thought was completely
inaccessible and by the way protects it
against the element because digitized
stuff isn't going to get hurt by like
moths okay but if you leave it in your
garage and it's just old film reels it
will
go check out legacy box right now it's
trusted by over a million people it's
easy it's safe every kit includes
everything you need to safely pack and
send your recorded moments i know the
folks who run it really trustworthy
legacy box is giving our listeners their
best deal of the year during their black
friday event visit legacybox.com shapiro
save an unreal 65 with limited
quantities ready to ship this deal will
go fast that is legacybox.com slash
apparel for 65 off
legacybox.com
shapiro okay so everybody is going crazy
over
omicron according to the associated
press quote the new potentially more
contagious omicron variants of the
coronavirus popped up in more european
countries on saturday just days after
being identified in south africa leaving
governments around the world scrambling
to stop the spread
question
what do you think you're going to do
seriously you tried lockdowns with delta
did it work how'd that work out for you
not well i've noticed that delta is
still going around in new york it's
still going around vermont high rates of
vaccination was still going around in
israel where nearly everyone was
vaccinated
how about this how about recognizing
that stopping the spread is not chiefly
the mechanism by which you defeat the
disease stopping the hospitalization and
the death is the mechanism by which you
chiefly stop the disease every single
scientist knows this everyone
okay everyone
unless this thing is more deadly in
which unless this is like super deadly
in which case
you have to ramp up the mrna vaccines
because they can right they're actually
talking about doing that right now now
that they know that these mrna vaccines
are highly effective if this thing
affects the the cells in a different way
if it if it has different spike proteins
for example
they can actually tailor a new vaccine
and have that thing rolling off the
lines in the next couple of months and
they've already talked about this
okay but stopping the spread
15 days to slow the spread has now
become nearly two years to slow this
bread gang and guess what the spread was
not slowed it was not delta completely
overcame all the talk about cloth masks
were going to save us all you know what
you noticed every place where people
went indoors
in large numbers
whether it was master unmasked there was
high spread germany high spread today
huge parts of europe high spread today
okay so all of this crap about how
you're going to stop we've got to slow
the spread slow this breath okay let me
just explain something to you ain't
happening it ain't happening you can
slow it temporarily very small period of
time and then all you're going to have
done is destroyed your economy prevented
people from living free lives and that's
it those are all the things you've
accomplished because it will eventually
wash through the population as it has
every single place every place
okay god
this is so delta was transmissible this
is more transmissible
new zealand tried this routine where
they shut all their borders and it turns
out it got in there anyway and then they
tried to do lockdowns and then
eventually like oh yeah we probably
should vaccinate everybody
okay so like the the i'm bewildered by
the fact that we're now a year and a
half into this thing more than a year
and a half
and we know
what we are going to know about covet
there is no mystery left when it comes
to covet really this is not a mysterious
disease we know that if you're in close
contact with other people in indoor
spaces you're likely going to get it
we also know it does not have to be
deadly for you if you get vaccinated
we also know that if you are young and
healthy it's not going to be deadly for
you
if you are young and healthy when i say
it's not going to be i mean like the the
number of people who are healthy and 30
years old who have died from code is
vanishingly small
so
what are you talking about
has omicron oh my god has it changed the
game and if so why explain
delta was already super transmissible so
now it's super duper transmissible under
omicro
okay
and
really and
the uk on saturday tightened its rules
on mask wearing well that'll fix it
probably and on testing of international
arrivals after finding two cases new
cases were confirmed saturday in germany
and italy with belgium israel and hong
kong also reporting that the variant has
been found in travelers okay so are we
just going to do this forever i assume
yes i assume there will be oh my craw
and then we'll move on to whatever the
next letter of the greek alphabet is and
we'll just keep going we'll just keep
going five years from now there'll be a
new variant be like wow this one's even
more transmissible than the last one be
like yeah but nobody's dying people will
be and all of our leaders like yes but
it's more transmissible like but no
one's dying
nope more transmissible
this is insanity okay now the reason
again that i'm focused in on the
deadlines is because who cares if it's
more transmissible if there aren't more
people getting hospitalized and dying
okay right now
and it's amazing the authorities we are
supposed to listen to are the people who
know the least
okay so i'm gonna give you the person
who knows the most okay this is the
south african doctor angelique cotzi she
identified omicron in south africa
here she is explaining what omicron is
and what it is not
the overall
uh patience uh that was recorded
yesterday was three thousand and around
about 3700 so our positivity rate is 9.2
percent
it is yes it is it is
more than we would have loved
it to be
but looking at the mildness of the
symptoms that we are seeing
currently there is no
reason for panicking
as we don't see severely ill patients
so then what the
what in the hell are we are we talking
about we're shutting down the globe
again the stock markets are dumping
because they're afraid that all these
morons who run our governments are just
going to shut everything down and the
doctor who discovered the variants in
south africa was like yeah we're seeing
mild disease
no increase in hospitalizations no
increase in deaths
are you all insane have you all lost
your damn the answer is they love the
control they love it so much and they
know again that the political the
political arena is stacked in favor of
control you want your politicians to you
know what it's our fault it's our fault
we as individual human beings living in
democracies we want our leaders to do
something do something save us protect
us here's the thing they can't
they cannot the only thing that our
leadership was capable of doing during
this entire pandemic was throwing money
at the big pharma companies and big
pharma companies came up with an answer
so
that's it those are all the things that
is what government has been able to do
but you out there you somehow think that
if your leader tells you to stay home
your leader has done you a favor your
leader has not done you a favor your
leader's an idiot your leader knows less
than this doctor
yeah i'm listening to the science she's
a doctor is she not the science but no
we're supposed to listen to dr anthony
fauci
who again has pretzeled himself into a
human aroboros by shoving his head so
far up his it's coming out his head
again
we're supposed to listen to him who's
been wrong every single step of the
pandemic but not the lady who discovered
omicron not that lady
you can't listen to her because she's
saying it's a mild disease
over in the uk
they're going to boost mask wearing they
said that anyone arriving in england
must take a pcr test for coven 19 on the
second day after the arrival and
self-isolate until they provide a
negative test if someone tests positive
for the omicron variant he said their
close contacts will also have to
self-isolate for 10 days regardless of
vaccination status
okay regardless of vaccination status so
before if somebody was a close contact
got coven and you're vaccinated you
didn't have to isolate
now because of omicron they have to
isolate
okay meanwhile many countries have
slapped restrictions on various southern
african countries including australia
brazil canada the eu iran japan new
zealand thailand and the united states
also
i i should note here that um israel
actually shut its borders to all
travelers again
again so that was great they were open
for like 12 hours
and then the israeli government because
again again all politics is stacked in
favor of lockdown fanatics
the israeli government was like no one
comes in again and by the way if you do
come in and get a special dispensation
the way that it works in israel you have
to take a pcr test you have to stay in a
quarantine hotel until you take the pcr
and get the results then even if you
come up negative you have to quarantine
for a week
wherever you're going and so you take a
second negative pcr test everyone has
lost their minds you wonder why the
markets are dumping it is not because of
omicron it's the markets are dumping
because the markets recognize that a
bunch of political leaders who are
stupider than your typical kitchen sink
are running the place
by the way how dumb are our political
leaders how politically motivated are
our political leaders all you have to do
to understand the answer to that
question is notice
that the reason that we name this thing
omicron
is because of politics i'll explain in
just one second first let's talk about a
great gift you can get somebody for the
holidays i'm talking about the gift of
pearl jewelry so you got a loved one and
a wife a sister mom
grandma okay you need to get her a great
gift for christmas or hanukkah or diwali
you need a great gift i'm talking about
the pearl source okay i've gotten my
wife stuff from the pearl source like
nearly every year for the last several
years also for other members of my
family including my daughters now just
beautiful beautiful stuff at the pearl
source you get the highest quality pearl
jewelry up to 70 off retail prices why
because the pearl source cuts out the
middle man by eliminating those crazy
jewelry store markups and selling
directly to you the consumer at the
pearl source you'll find the largest
selection of pearls available anywhere
each jewelry piece is custom made
specifically for you with global supply
chain problems and shipping carriers
expecting major delays as you get closer
to the holidays now is the time to start
shopping for the holiday season don't
wait the pearl source offers fast and
free two-day shipping on every order
with zero contact delivery
everything comes beautifully packaged in
an elegant jewelry box it is ready to be
given as a gift if you're not sure
she'll love it no worries the pearl
source comes with a no hassle 60-day
money-back guarantee with free return
shipping it is risk-free i know the
people who run it pearl wonderful family
owned business it is a terrific business
and their product is just gorgeous for a
limited time listeners to my show can
take 20 off your entire order don't wait
until it's too late to do the holiday
shopping go to
thepearlsource.com enter promo code
bennett check out for 20 off your entire
order if you want fine pearl jewelry at
the best prices online go straight to
the source the pearls that's the
pearlsource.com backslash ben enter
promo code ben at checkout okay so
how much is politics infusing how we do
public health these days you know why
this thing is called omicron you know
why
the reason why is because they didn't
want to name it new okay new was the
next
one in the in the greek alphabet and
they were afraid that people are stupid
enough to think that if it was called
the new variant they'd be like oh you
mean the new variant like n-e-w
so even if they had who cares but the
real reason is because the one after
that
is psi
okay psi which is the greek letter
psi is spelled x-i
and you know what else is spelled x-i
the name of china's leader xi jinping
okay so even though they are not
hourly different right a-u-r-a-l-y
they're not oral
they sound they sound different to the
ear
when you spell them
they look the same right the greek
letter psi is spelled x i and so is xi
jinping
and so who was like well we don't wanna
we don't wanna make that we don't wanna
remind people this thing came from china
that would cause racism
ah you people you people
a spokesperson jose revec said quote nu
is too easily confounded with nu and xy
was not used because it is a common last
name oh really
is that what this is you know delta is
kind of a common name too like we have
an entire airline called delta here in
in the united states
i noticed also alpha is a pretty
commonly used term
so so is beta
so is gamma
i i'm noticing that um your your
sudden shyness about using the greek
alphabet started right about the time
that your chinese pay masters got
uptight maybe we should call it the
winnie the pooh variant in order to make
sure that the uh that we are
not targeting xi jinping who definitely
definitely does not look like winnie the
pooh 100 does not look like winnie the
pooh
okay so
we don't know anything about this virus
okay the only thing that we know about
omicron is that it has more spiked
proteins which means that it is more
transmissible and may evade whatever vax
immunity was provided for that spike
protein okay by the way what the studies
tend to show is that natural immunity
has a has a broader spectrum of disease
prevention than does vaccine immunity
according to the israeli studies
specifically because the the vaccines
really target only one spike protein
whereas natural immunity can cover more
than one it covers a sort of a gamut
okay so
here is dr anthony fauci the greatest of
all doctors and he says well you know
the big risk here is that it appears
more transmissible yes we know i don't
care
i don't care
i assumed every i already once i assume
100 of people are either going to get
immunity through natural immunity or
vaccines there's no more than 100
there's not 101 of humans
okay it doesn't work that way so once
i've already made that assumption you
can't scare me by telling me that more
people are going to get it i know
everybody's going to get it i'm aware
and
by the way pfizer has already come out
and they said oh yeah by the way we can
rework the vaccines pretty quickly so if
it turns out that this does evade
immunity in some severe way within a
hundred days we can rework the pfizer
vaccine in order to in order to
generate new immunity anyway here is
here's anthony fauci trying to freak you
out about the transmissibility of this
disease
it has the molecular characteristics
that would strongly suggest
that it would be more transmissible it
has a bunch of mutations a disturbingly
large number of mutations in the spike
protein which is the business end of the
virus which really binds particularly in
one particular component of that spike
that binds to the receptors in your body
in your nose and your in your
nasopharynx and in your lung the
mutations would strongly suggest
that it would be more transmissible and
that it might evade some of the
protection
of monoclonal antibodies in convalescent
plasma and perhaps
even antibodies they're induced by
vaccine
okay but here is the thing if you evade
the the antibodies that are induced by
the vaccine that doesn't mean that you
don't have t cell and b cell memory that
can still help you your body know how to
fight this thing and also again we have
therapeutics coming online we have so
here's the question for anthony fauci
there is scaring the crap out of
everybody scaring the pants out of
everybody right they wow you know they
might evade the vaccines
okay one what are we talking about are
we talking about evading the vaccines so
far as infection or are we talking about
evading the vaccines so far as the
hospitalization and death rate again the
only person i have heard who knows
anything about the hospitalizations and
deaths is the south african doctor who
discovered this thing who said it's
causing mild disease why is everyone
freaking out
but i'm going to listen to anthony fauci
okay so then anthony thatches asked does
this cause more severe disease he's like
i don't know
i don't know is not good enough for you
to lock down the entire society again
especially because it didn't work the
first time even by the way if it did
cause higher
rates of hospitalization and death
you would have to explain why lockdowns
are the solution to that because they
weren't the first time sweden didn't
lock down and sweden now has the 56th
highest death per million rate
okay everyone is ripping on sweden
sweden did better and mostly all ali all
here here's anthony fauci again
admitting he doesn't know if this causes
more death
do we know if it causes more severe
disease
great question george and we don't know
that in fact we were on the phone with
our south african colleagues who have
been incredibly good
about being so transparent about what's
going on there on friday and we're
meeting with them again today late a
little bit later on in a couple of hours
to try and find out if the cases that
they've identified that clearly are
caused by this variant what is the level
of severity in that hopefully it would
be light but you know south africa has a
relatively small proportion of the
population that's vaccinated so you got
to take that into the equation when
you're trying to figure out where this
virus is really going and what its
impact is going to be
okay so in other words you have given us
like the wrong information you just want
to scare the living daylights out of us
in a second we'll get to more of this
because it's
the markets are reacting you are
reacting everybody is reacting not to
the virus they're reacting to the
insanity and stupidity of our public
health officials we'll get to more on
this in one second first if you're
looking for ways to skip the trip to the
post office and dodge the hectic holiday
shopping traffic why not save time and
money with stamps.com we've been using
it here at daily wires since 2017
because why would you go to the post
office when you can just get all the
great services of the post office from
your home office or from your office
stamps.com lets you compare rates print
labels and access exclusive discounts on
ups and usps services all year long it
just makes sense especially if your
business sends more mail and packages
during the holidays whether you're
selling online or running an office or
side hustle stamps.com can save you so
much time money and stress during the
holidays
access all the post office and ups
shipping services you need without
taking the trip and get discounts you
can't find anywhere else like up to 40
off usps rates and 76 off ups going to
the post office instead of using
stamps.com is kind of like taking the
stairs instead of the elevator you're
just going up a couple of floors sure
you know go to the post office i suppose
but if you're actually sending a lot of
packages you really need stamps.com
you'll save tons of time and money save
time and money this holiday season with
stamps.com sign up with promo coach
shapiro for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial free postage
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com click
the microphone at the top of the page
enter code shapiro again use stamps.com
enter code shapiro okay so
all of our public health officials right
now should be focused on one question
and one question alone
and that is
is this thing more deadly and yet that
seems to be the thing that people are
worried about the least
okay so there is there is no evidence at
this point that omicron is more deadly
and in fact it would sort of be lie the
history of viral transmissibility that
there would be a new variant
of an old virus that somehow has become
more deadly
usually the virus has become more
transmissible but not as deadly that's
typically the way that these viruses
work the reason being viruses want hosts
that replicate they don't want to kill
off the hosts they
they typically want to be able to breed
and then move on to the next person and
if you kill the hose the person doesn't
seed it in as many people
but our public health officials are
operating from the abundance of caution
model hey here's the abundance of
caution here's the problem
there is literally no limit to the
abundance of caution model if the idea
is that every time there's variant you
shut down all of society
i'm just wondering when you don't shut
down society for what i mean there could
be a new
the cold is a virus in fact the cold is
a corona virus
next year there's going to be a new a
new form of the cold the common cold
this is actually a bundle of
coronaviruses and next year there will
be a new form of the flu
should we as a society lock down every
year during flu season because after all
you don't know this could be the year
when there is a more deadly version of
the flu
where where are the limits the abundance
of caution principle here
and the answer is there are none
what you normally do with the disease is
you wait until the disease demonstrates
signs of deadliness before you start to
treat people with radioactivity
if you went to the doctor and the doctor
was like listen
we've got some cells over here we're not
sure what they are
but
you know it like they could be benign
they could be they they could be not
benign they could be cancerous
they could be malignant we just don't
know so we have decided that we are
going to zap you we're gonna we're gonna
give you we're gonna give you
all of the chemotherapy you could
possibly want we're just gonna fill your
body with the chemo you'd be like um no
i'm gonna go get a second opinion
because before you do all this damage to
my body i would like to know what it is
that i am looking at
because it's possible that the treatment
is worse than the disease and when it
comes to how we as a society have dealt
with with kovid i think it is fair to
say at this point that the treatment has
been worse than the disease because the
treatment didn't even stop the disease
the treatment in many cases facilitated
the disease so you got the worst of all
of it
got what countries locked down that were
not islands major countries that were
locked down after the virus was widely
seeded everyone went home and infected
family members many of those people died
and you destroyed the economy and you
made people dependent on the government
and you prepared a western population
for the possibility of authoritarian
rule from above
and so now all those same authoritarians
are like well you know what maybe we
should just continue doing this forever
after all abundance of caution abundance
listen if you're 75 years old and
immunocompromised maybe you should live
your life under the abundance of caution
rule because pretty much anything can
kill you if you're 80 years old and you
are suffering from some sort of
lymphatic cancer
probably you should be super careful no
matter what you do but if you're 30
years old and you're healthy you cannot
live under the abundance of caution
regime
and by the way neither can any whole
economy you cannot there's no way that
entire economies can live under the
abundance of caution regime because in
the end somebody's gonna have to pay for
all this crap
we've spent more money over the last two
years than any time in human history you
think we can just keep doing that while
shutting down the economy simultaneously
i know randy weingarten today is
celebrating oh macron because it means
that many of our teachers will never
have to go back to school but guess what
parents will continue schooling their
kids
all that's going to happen is you're
going to facilitate the vast flow of
people from blue states to red states in
the united states
and the flow from public schools to
private schools
and and you're going to see people just
start to dismiss the regime entirely
it'll break america's already breaking
down into two groups of people the
compliance and the non-compliance
now when i say non-compliance i don't
mean people who are refusing to get
backs i mean people who just don't
believe that the government ought to
have the authority to shut down your
entire life because they feel like
abundance of caution is their duty
versus people who are like well if the
government tells me so then it's almost
in a religious pagan obsession with the
idea that these jackasses wearing white
robes no more than anyone else including
the people who discovered the disease
so the stock market has been tanking
over the last couple of days
according to the wall street journal u.s
companies responded to the new coven 19
variant with a mix of both concern and
confusion some executives scheduled
calls with internal teams to assess the
threat or peppered health advisors with
questions while many cautioned they
would hold off on making changes to
operations until more is known the fast
spreading omicron variant is pushing
companies in a range of industries to
consider how safety measures and new
workflows created during the peak of the
pandemic could be reinstated
it also served as a reminder executive
say that navigating through unknowns of
coven 19 is a new reality of corporate
management
okay um
or alternatively they're just waiting to
see what the government forces them to
do
brian fialco chief executive jet code
delivery a houston trucking and
logistics company said it's important to
not catastrophize and not to kind of
just jump to the worst you have to take
it as a real threat it's a risk how
severe is the risk we don't know
said he would watch for guidance from
u.s health authorities
okay well here is the problem our
authorities suck they suck so anthony
fauci he came out he said it's too early
to say if we need more lockdowns but we
have to prepare for the worst well thank
you sir that is very that is excellent
guidance i wow without that what would i
have done today without that that
god-like guidance from science from dr
anthony fauci the greatest of all
doctors except for dr joe biden and dr
jay i mean wha what would i have done
without without the wisdom of a man who
tells me that he doesn't know anything
but we should prepare for the worst
the hell did okay that's it i guess i
have to build a bomb basement and build
a bomb shelter today got to prepare for
the worst guys
next thing you know there might be a
nuclear attack here's dr anthony fauci
should we expect to be seeing more
lockdowns again new lockdowns more
mandates
you know i don't know george it's really
too early to say we just really need to
as i've said so often prepare for the
worst
and it may not be that we're going to
have to go the route that people are
saying this we don't know a lot about
this virus so we want to prepare as best
as we can
but it may turn out that this
preparation although important may not
necessarily push us to the next level
okay
so thanks that's that's super helpful dr
fauci it may not push us to the next
level but you got to prepare for the
worst meanwhile joe biden was asked
about this
and um by the way he stumbles out to the
media to talk i'm noticing something
that's not on his face right here while
he's very close to the media weird
i've been told that masks are the
all-purpose solution to everything on
earth in fact if we were all smart what
we would do is we'd go get those
costumes from squid game maybe
those guys look safe from covid
i mean yeah they're shooting people but
they do look safe from covet
i mean they have like the big mouse with
like the triangle on their face and
they're wearing like radioactive suits
and everything here is here is joe biden
wearing nothing in nantucket right
bellying his own his own we've got a
mask masking is the solution to all
things now saying he's not concerned
about the stock market sell-offs
significantly today what's your response
to that
expected they always do
does it worry you at all
okay so then he's asked okay so he was
asked about the travel ban do they put
in place a travel ban from south africa
now here's the thing about the travel
ban
we learned that the original travel ban
really was not particularly effective
right trump put in place a travel ban in
late january and it was called by joe
biden's xenophobic and most of the media
xenophobic when trump does a thing as we
all know it is xenophobic when joe biden
does it it's just a kindly old gentleman
who's doing exactly the same thing as
the last guy but he's nice so it's good
now right when he separates families at
the border it's good
when when he's got the the
when when he has ice out there rounding
people up and keeping them under bridges
that's good because he's a nice guy
because he's joe biden because he's old
and stupid
donald trump is a malevolent evil force
in the universe and so when donald trump
does it at xenophobic when joe biden
does it it's just wonder and and joy so
joe biden announced that there would be
a travel ban put in place on some of
these african countries now here's the
reality if it's in these countries
already it's already here it's already
in hong kong it's already in israel it's
already in britain likes everywhere so
all these travel bans are going to be
for naught and we kind of know that
already so it's basically just pasting a
band-aid on what is already a wound
underneath that's infected okay it's not
going gonna help particularly a lot
okay but but here is uh here is joe
biden he was asked about the travel ban
he said monday and people like why are
you doing it monday why not immediately
if it's like there's a weird have you
noticed there's a weird tendency in this
administration to clear things emergency
and then sort of amble on down taking
their time to do them
and we need a vax mandate today fax
mandate now today four months from now
we need a travel ban that travel ban has
to kick into place because it is urgent
man we gotta stop this oh mikron we have
to stop it we have to stop it today
monday
isn't it friday sir here is a here's joe
biden trying to explain
mr president why are we waiting until
monday sir why not
oh well you know he doesn't have a good
reason but that's okay by the way again
joe biden uh in order to explain to
omicron it was very important for him to
take off that mask i'm just gonna point
out here he is he literally right before
this he literally walks down the street
he's wearing a mask
away from people he walks up to the
media takes off the mask to talk to the
media coughs into his hand
and get you get the impression these
folks aren't actually taking this as
seriously as they want you to take it
you must obey them but they must obey no
one
you've already gotten my release he is
walking down the street
carefully because it's wet outside takes
off that mask there's no travel
to and from south africa and six other
countries
announces the travel ban and he's about
to hack directly into his hands
solve the problem guys
disease solved
yep by the way he was also shopping
massless so literally there was he was
in nantucket staying with a donor friend
by the way because he's he's super not
corrupt in any way he literally is in a
store there's a giant
sign on the front of the store that says
required face covering and you can see
him through the window with no mask on
all your leaders are taking omicron
super seriously they should set the
standards for which businesses should be
open
they should mandate that businesses
force their customers to mask
or vax except for joe biden
who is apparently immune to the disease
that's that's amazing joe biden is the
only person on earth who's completely
safe that's that's you know good good i
mean good for america he's the only
person on earth who is completely safe
from the from the virus okay in one
second we will get to the
ineffectiveness of the travel ban
because at this point it's kind of a
little late is the truth once it's
already seeded places it's not gonna
make all that much of a difference but
we'll get to that in a moment first
let's talk about a gift that keeps on
giving you joy and comfort every day all
year long it's a gift that looks great
it feels great i'm talking about the
magic of the x chair okay i love the
extra i'll give you a massage it's
temperature control it's basically like
god made a chair and then he bestowed it
upon humanity and it can grace your
turkish and the rest of your body every
time you sit down at your desk so you
know sitting at your desk it's not that
great but i will tell you upon the extra
it's like floating on a bed made of
clouds it's basically like being
massaged by angels this is the x-chair
not only is extra the world's greatest
office chair with its patented lmax
technology it doubles as a massage chair
and it can either cool or warm your back
can your office chair do that or did the
schlub who was at your job before just
leave you his office chair now you're
just sitting in the creases that he made
with his butt you should have your own
magical ex chair here is xtra's holiday
gift to you save 100 off your extra just
by purchasing it at xchairshapiro.com
right now that's the letter x chair
dot com x-chair has a 30-day guarantee
of complete comfort you can finance your
purchase for as little as 30 bucks a
month go to extra shapiro.com and save
xchairshapiro.com
already more of this in just one moment
first if you're a fan of my colleague
matt walsh you're going to want to hear
this the daily wire host and former
virginia resident has just written his
first children's book i've read it more
than once i can tell you it's a very
important piece of literature you're
going to want on your kids shelf matt
will be launching his book tonight on
tucker carlson's show you're not going
to want to miss it it is a vital read
for all small children tune in tonight
to fox news at 8 pm eastern 7 pm central
for a very special announcement from our
very own matt walsh also remember today
today the last day to get 50 off your
daily dailywear membership by using code
dw50 we need your support here at
dailywear because we are fighting and we
need you to join the fight with us not
only you're going to get the merch
discounts we have great ben shapiro
merch by the way like awesome stuff that
you're going to want to give to family
and friends particularly if they're on
the left because
they must experience the joy it's that
that time of year but also we have a
bunch of amazing content we have a lot
of projects in the queue for 2022. we
need more members to make all of that
possible members are what gave us the
ability to pick up gina carano
after disney plus decided to basically
just cap her and we we picked her up we
were able to do a movie with her it was
going to be released next year we are
super pumped about that we're able to
launch our investigative journalism team
that made a huge difference in loudoun
county and in that virginia
gubernatorial race we are currently
embroiled in a lawsuit with the bite
administration directly over their
garbage vacs mandate you can help us out
today is the last day the last day to
get our best membership deal of the year
use code dw50 for 50
off your membership we need you in the
fight so please join us in the fight we
always appreciate your help you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
okay so joe biden's big move is to do
exactly what donald trump did but not
xenophobic like right he's gonna do a
travel ban and that's supposed to fix
everything here is um the problem um
it's not going to work and the reason
it's not going to work is because it's
already seated here
okay so the bite administration is
trying to double down on boosters at
this point
um again the data on omicron
is not sufficient to say that a 30 year
old needs a booster shot at this point
uh fauci said it is conceivable if not
likely that booster shots will provide
at least a partial shield of protection
against the new variant he did not cite
any data to to explain why he said that
that is the case
also the experts are saying uh yeah by
the way these these um
these travel
bans are not really going to to do
anything uh fauci has said it is highly
unlikely that vaccines offer no
protection against the new variant the
who says it says it's working with a
large number of researchers around the
world to understand the impact omicron
would have on existing vaccines and
antivirals
so they don't even know you know what
this thing does to the to the vaccine at
this point and they're like well what if
we just keep shooting you full of of
more vaccine how about we find out what
it does first i know it's kind of crazy
to suggest that maybe we should be
guided by data as opposed to just like
randomly jabbing people at this point
again i'm very pro-vaccine but i like
data also and you've provided me no data
sir so this is unhelpful as far as the
travel bans so joe biden remember not a
xenophobe he's not
he's a different old white guy than the
last old white guy he is not xenophobic
so um fauci comes out he's like yeah
maybe it's already here which is awkward
for us a little
is it possible it's already in the u.s
you know
of course anything is possible we don't
know that there's no indication that it
is right now it seemed to have been
restricted there were some cases
that originated in south africa and that
went to botswana and people who traveled
and found out they were infected and one
that had gone actually to hong kong so
there's a lot of travel you never know
exactly where we are and that's the
reason why we're getting together to
them to try and get the precise
molecular makeup of it so you could
actually test for it
okay meanwhile fauci is trying to so so
he's saying it's probably already here
and then he's like oh yeah but maybe the
maybe the travel bans will buy us some
time
uh will they explain
you know it will slow things down george
travel bans when you have a highly uh
transmissible virus never completely
would get the virus to coming uh prevent
it from coming into the country no way
that's gonna happen but what what you
can do is you can delay it enough to get
us better prepared and that's the thing
that people need to understand if you're
gonna do the travel ban the way we've
done now and that we're implementing
right now
utilize the time that you're buying to
fill in the gaps
okay so um
maybe that's true and maybe it's not i
will say that a travel ban that is
geared toward south africa alone and not
toward anybody who has traveled to south
africa or from south africa and and
people who have been with those people
like once it's already widely seated
it's a little bit late for that but
again it's not xenophobia unless donald
trump does it is the rule voucher by the
way again he just keeps throwing out all
of these maybes and the babies are
designed to scare the crap out of you so
now he's saying well maybe we'll do a
vax mandate uh to just travel to get on
a plane now again this is insane the
reason it's insane is because
the the planes have been like one of the
safest places this entire pandemic
they've got the hepa filters okay planes
have not been a central vehicle for
transmission of the virus throughout the
entire pandemic
which was counter to what a lot of
people thought no evidence was ever
provided that that if you were on a
plane with a lot of other people that
you were more likely to get this than if
you were at a crowded grocery store for
example
but anthony fauci is now saying maybe
we'll force you to get the vax so that
you will get on a plane come on
right now
we hope that people who get vaccinated
and who will follow the appropriate
recommendations that air travel will
continue to be safe and right now air
travel is when you say travel in general
causes a risk of increased transmission
it's the whole process of traveling
going to the airport being in an airport
in congregate setting people taking
their masks off that's the issue that
we've got to make sure that we adhere to
more more closely and more firmly
okay so in other words it's not the
planes but we might force you to fax
anyway to get on a plane because you
know it's the whole process of travel oh
you mean like life
oh yeah it's it's true like life is a
process in which travel is a part he's
like well it's not just the travel so
you're at the airport and then you're in
the car before you go to the airport and
then go to marshalls to pick up a
suitcase in order so you can go to the
airport and then when you get off the
plane at the airport you might be hungry
so you go to a restaurant you pick up
some chop suey like what are you talking
about what are you talking about why
would you let these
jackasses run your life why what
evidence have they provided to you that
they are good at this any okay so faulty
was then asked about um
representing science because he was
saying like why are you attacked why are
you attacked dr fauci these are always
the question he's asked by our legacy
media instead of being asked why do you
shift your opinion every five seconds
why do you seem to do the bidding of the
biden administration while rolling your
eyes during trump press conferences why
is it that you're willing to try out
whatever propagandistic line joe biden
is trotting out today
and why is it that we should listen to
you after you've gotten every element of
this wrong at some point during the
pandemic you've provided no forecasting
ability whatsoever you haven't even
provided diagnostic ability throughout
this pandemic the data you've provided
have been counter counterproductive
you've lost the trust of the american
people instead of asking actual tough
questions the legacy means you're like
why are people so mean to you dr fauci
can we make another fawning documentary
that shows a picture of you in your home
on your computer with a giant poster of
you next to you
by the way that that is one i'm never
going to understand and a dead giveaway
that somebody is a douchebag is if there
is a picture of them in their house with
a giant picture of them right next to
them dead giveaway or a douchebag we're
not talking about like a family picture
with you and the rest of the members of
your family sound like a portrait of you
next to you
okay like
that is the douchebag giveaway
go check out his documentary it is there
anyway here here is dr anthony fauci
being asked about why he's criticized
and his answer is of course because he
is science he is
like like emperor palpatine is the
senate he is the science
well if they get up and criticize
science nobody's gonna know what they're
talking about
but if they get up and really aim their
bullets at tony fauci well people could
recognize there's a person there so it's
easy to criticize but they're really
criticizing science
because i represent science
that's dangerous to me that's more
dangerous
than the slings and the arrows that get
thrown at me
okay so i have a question when you
criticize jay bhattacharya from stanford
when you criticize marti makari from
johns hopkins university when you
criticize scott atlas from stanford when
you when you criticize all those people
are you are you attacking the science or
are you just attacking a particular
scientific perspective on the data why
is it that only anthony pouch is the
science why is he the voice of science
he's bad at this he's just bad at this
okay and then he's asked specifically
about the idea of being prosecuted okay
so there have been a lot of republicans
ted cruz rand paul who suggested that
anthony fauci lied to them about gain of
function research in wuhan which he kind
of did the way that he has avoided the
actual perjury question is by redefining
gain of function cogain of function
typically means according to anthony
fauci that you increase the
transmissibility of a virus within a
species it doesn't mean that you make a
virus transmissible across species and
now that is a really formal definition
of gain of function research that does
not meet the smell test but that's what
anthony thought she's been relying upon
so rand paul and ted cruz have been
going after him and anthony fauci is
asked about this and he gets super
pissed and then cackles like like a bond
villain here
senator cruz told the attorney general
you should be prosecuted yeah
i'd have to laugh at that
i should be prosecuted
do you think that this is
about making you a scapegoat to deflect
of course president trump of course
you have to be asleep not to figure that
one out well there are a lot of
republican senators uh taking aim
at this right that's okay i'm just to do
my job and i'm going to be saving lives
and they're going to be lying
i'm going to be saving okay
how many lives hasn't anthony fought you
saved
really
how many
also
my favorite is humorless laughs humorous
less are some of my favorites so when
you're asked a question you don't like
the question and so you just sort of
laugh but there's no laughter in the
eyes that's my favorite kind of
political after kamala harris is really
good at it that's when you like laugh
and it's like this
love that from anthony fauci
what about january said what about
january sex hell are you talking about
we're talking about whether you lied
about gain of function research in muhan
and whether you suck at your job that's
what we're talking about right now what
the hell does that have to do with trump
what a political hack he is remember
that time when he was not a political
hack or was supposed to not be yeah he's
a political hack but we should always
listen to these people they're the
experts remember they've provided you no
data that omicron is more deadly or that
it will lead to your hospitalization we
they provide no data the vaccines don't
stand up to omicron they've provided no
data whatsoever that natural immunity
doesn't provide any protection against
hospitalization or death from omicron
but listen to them because they will
laugh at you if not and they are the
science if you fall for this one
honestly we're a civilization that gets
what we deserve if we have decided to
worship at the altar of idols like
anthony fauci rather than looking at
actual hard data that they refuse to
provide
all right we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
coming up soon the matt wall show airs 1
30 pm eastern be sure to check it out
over at dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show